[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
was an animal you had to have sex with
though forced
yeah probably
sheep
i'm from ireland i think they do that
[ __ ] all the time yeah sheep i think
because because it's soft yeah and
they're don't laugh at me yeah i think
because they're soft yeah and and even
if they get upset they're just like
[Laughter]
so it's not that bad
for me it would be panda
oh because you're so cute well i don't
even think that's true and you could i
could here's the thing if i was having
sex with an animal i wouldn't want them
to think hey
hey there yeah right
somebody [ __ ] me
right i wouldn't want them to think that
you just want it to be a thing i don't
want them to go hey there well then if
you [ __ ] a big animal then what i
would do with a panda is you give them a
grade a bamboo oh like hi i love the
chew that [ __ ] why goo bamboo right so
i'd be like here's bamboo they'd be like
hey there
and then i would you know
and they'd be just so focused on but
don't think it's so [ __ ] up from the
eucalypt is that eucalyptus is is that
pandas
no matt who eats eucalyptus
sloths and they black out right they
just pass out yeah yeah they get really
[ __ ] high because sloth they go well
sloths live in trees how can you get
them because i thought about this right
honestly i don't know why i thought
about this but in papua new guinea
there's a lot of slots right i didn't
know there is right yeah so what they
would do is they would go to papua new
guinea right and sloths you don't know i
googled this i don't know why i don't
know why it's researched this but sloths
they come to the ground while they take
a [ __ ] or they go to the bathroom i've
seen this right i've seen this in costa
rica they come to the ground right yeah
so imagine a bunch of sloths in the tree
right
where you going johnny
it's lots like i gotta
take your [ __ ] gotta take a [ __ ] i'll be
right back and as soon as he lands get
him 50 dudes come out they form a train
yeah right
and then he trying to run away
right
and he's like and his buddies are going
run
frankie
i'm
trying
to run
right and he gets on the tree
right he's already been raped 40 50
times right
and and people are like jumping up and
tagging him
right and just ripping them as he goes
up the taller the taller guys
yeah the tyler guys right i mean that
would be a nightmare they'd be extinct
let's just put everything into context
though okay okay sold out that's not
what i'm going to say but it is sold out
it was
all mexican and whites again no blacks
at this show three
three we counted a lot of asians there's
a good amount of asians yeah yeah but no
black people which i love
so um for you because you don't get any
black fans
you know um you don't
they don't like you do you want to make
me angry or no no of course not yeah
because i'm just no i have to address
that okay
no don't roll your eyes i did when you
roll your eyes it's so gross
so um
when i play michigan or yeah cleveland
or you you they come out
black people yeah
okay so take a picture i will take a
picture with all your black fans yeah
and upload it and then you know i would
let's make a contest to see who how many
more black fans i have than you fine
okay fine um yesterday
yesterday was
yesterday was father's day and uh oh boy
i miss my dad and the thing is
i wanted to um write a father's day um
song and um i told you i was gonna do
that too yeah you promised me and i
thought you weren't gonna do it i'm
being serious and and i forgot about it
and then we were sitting here outside
waiting for you because you were late um
i wasn't late i was getting you
sugar-free red bull rudy
was i getting sugar-free red bull yeah
see
okay but was were we here were we here
before i called them dude you called me
it doesn't matter no no you called me
all right can we do the father's day
what are you angry about you always do
this to me you trample on me trample
trample your turnip your trampoline
trampoline you travel trample that's you
travel trample yeah yeah go ahead
trampoline so um you know i while we
were waiting for you um because we were
early cause i got sugar will you go yeah
and i um i wrote a song real quick
because i write a lot of music on my
garage band so i just came up with i
have an old older like weird song i mean
so i wanted to i wrote a song for my dad
okay let's hear it all right
daddy i love you
daddy why you died
happy father's day daddy
daddy i can fly
daddy i miss you
why are you dead
[Music]
i'm sorry i took photos of you while you
were dead
and sent it to the heart says what was
in my head
you were dead and i whipped out my
phone
i can't [ __ ] believe i did that [ __ ]
i'm all alone miss you daddy i love you
okay there we go that's a song
very good i ignore this [ __ ] whenever
this first of all let me guess i haven't
seen this video yet let me guess he
calls me sleepy eyes
let's hear it yeah let me
let me make an assumption here that this
redneck is going to say something about
my eyes
okay let's hear it go ahead bobby lee
you [ __ ] hear me bobby lee sleepy
[ __ ]
all right wake up dawg i'm that [ __ ]
alarm clock son yeah come get some you
wanted your little gristle animal come
get it no
come freaking get it dude there's cat
with them new bangs dude i'll jump off
the bottom rope and [ __ ] still take
you out you bastard
yeah you're gonna hit that red head on
the way down dude i [ __ ] oh oh yeah
i'll catch that dude with you get a
little cinnamon on your elbow i'll catch
i do with my yeah one of my hoofs
i'll catch that chatty hollywood elite
with one of my hooks
yeah he is hollywood oh dawg time i'm
sorry i can't do the show i'm i'm on set
yeah i'm on set i watched somebody
else's stretch
i was on set
yeah dude
setting my deck of nuts
when i was a kid
yeah there was a kid named brady
and i i think that he was born literally
with no brain right right like he was
just empty yeah
but i hung out with him because this
dude right could pull
a stop sign
right out of the ground right off the
ground with his hand at the age of 12.
yeah
you you woman do it do it
you go good
and pull it out yeah right and i use
brady because i'm the you know
every brady has a guy like me 100
percent a little guy yeah like you know
master blaster master blood consumer
best blaster
pull up master bath blaster
yeah master blaster
[Laughter]
right that's that's brady that's brady
and you and that's me on top i'm the guy
telling him what to do right go this way
yeah go this way
brendan schaab right
is
the same
right that theo so theo's right yeah
telling him what to do yeah right it's
that redneck right that twangy little
[ __ ] that hicka dude
i didn't want to say in bread because it
would be a compliment wait it's true
yeah it'd be a compliment to him
yeah and yeah yeah a few of my cousins
yeah it's a mix of like family blood
yeah he's such a hick fart he's a hit
yeah you know how you can tell he has an
eye that just wanders what about these
two douchies are doing right is that
just trying to provoke a war with real
warriors right with real world yeah yeah
they try to provoke a war with true
warriors yeah you know what with you
know what we're the mental we have
mental capacities yeah yeah
here's the thing you and i say we're
stupid all the time yeah we do that as a
fun we go we're dumb and we're not that
smart
these two guys yeah honestly
i'm not kidding pound for pound the
[Laughter]
that's the brightest thing you've ever
said yeah because you're right and there
was always something about them yeah
when i would hang out with them right i
would feel uneasy
right right like you know um if i used a
word right they they couldn't comprehend
yeah i mean yeah and um but what i
realized was is that i'm dealing with
people that are just not mentally
quite there because of either their
heritage
ceo right
or um or because they got hit in the
head so many times shop yeah
yeah and so that you just nailed it in
the butt right there they are just um
bottom dumb
you know what an anglerfish is like sure
you know it has the light and pull up a
picture of an anglerfish yeah yeah this
is what theo and shaub look like if they
were if they were together a fish if the
own shop were uh a fish that that's them
there they are
no no the third one the orange one the
most aren't yeah that's the only thing
that's what they look like yeah i can't
believe you got into a fist fight with
kate blanchett that's crazy [ __ ] fist
by the way kate blanchett
bobby called me and she i didn't get a
fist fight with her she came to his room
she came up to his room and she was like
it's me it's kate blanchett and um bobby
said
oh what's up and he opens the door and
she goes they delivered my chicken
strips to your room and bobby had
already eaten all the chicken strips and
she's like you fat [ __ ] and they got
into a fist fight and you punched
blanche can i tell you my relationship
with kate blanchard yeah what is it okay
i'll just give you an example so please
two the two
the second to the last day i was there
yeah
i i went to the restaurant that was in
the hotel
and kate was there with gina gershon
they were having breakfast right okay
and they both look at me and they go
what's up bobby and i walked by so fast
and with my phone and my no one was not
i wasn't talking to anybody why did you
do that because i i get so nervous
around cake
around them right yeah i go hey good
morning right and i'm really it's weird
the morning yeah yeah let's get the
morning right and i just
like
run past yeah and then i'll eventually
come back because then i'll sit there
and i'll go
we should have done that man
nothing that you're a [ __ ] meth
addict yeah man yeah and weird right
yeah
sorry guys i just woke up i needed to
get my coffee you know i mean that type
i'm like a weird guy dude don't forget
about theo theo is the kind of guy
i won't forget don't forget about theo
i'm
the kind of guy i don't even i don't
know if you know this but theo yeah theo
used to work in a bowling alley when he
was a kid
right mm-hmm and he would set the pins
yeah right and there was a little old
lady who was 97 years old this was her
97th birthday party yeah and she just
found out that day that it ain't working
that well anymore oh right and she said
all i want for my birthday
is to have a perfect game
yeah right perfect game means all the
strikes 300 yeah theo catches wind at us
right while he's in the back
fixing the bowling machines
bowling pin machines and so what does he
do he knows she's 97 she can't see the
pins yeah
as she rolls every time no matter what
he makes it go down yeah first frame
second frame third frame
and this is crazy right yeah this is
crazy on the last frame yeah he said
i'm gonna let her do it on her own
because i believe in her yeah she lets
the ball go sure enough
strike on her own she gets a 300. she
gets a 300 of all yeah yeah that's the
kind of guy that theo is and by the way
the old lady wasn't even white and i
know that's tough for him yeah but it
wasn't even a white old lady she was
black what was it was a black old lady i
read that and i know that you know theo
inside was like i don't know if i can
help you yeah yeah yeah but
he did anyway he went against his family
tradition he went against his innate
right instinct yeah another thing that
he did was um you know lately chinese
people are being hurt
in public in public because of the
roanoke because they have because it's
trump
the chinese virus right but they've been
doing it for a long time
right i'm just saying this back in the
day for where he's from
the south
he's from louisiana louisiana small town
small town yeah and there was one
chinese guy there
there was one yes and all the you know
southerners they used to push they used
to take uh you know those like mini bats
and mini bats for carnivals and you know
one guy would go
i'm gonna swing it i'm going to swing it
right on his forehead tommy
right when i hit it like this you hit
another one here oh right so you you
know me so he wouldn't even know where
to go whoa right so yeah so they would
hit him and you know what i mean because
if he hit him this way you'd go forward
yeah right but they were here and he
would go blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah and every day and then
one day right
one guy named bubba smith
that was his name i okay you read a box
i've heard about that yeah he pushes the
chinese man right leroy chan was his
name chen yeah and leroy
was falling down to concrete oh what did
theo do what theo
laid on the ground no yes
laid on the ground like this right right
lee roy broke his fall
wow yeah
and they just laid there for like 45
minutes did the theo say and leroy would
go thank you so much thank you don't
worry about it man no no no no sweating
off my heart
no sweat off my paws yeah so he's done
so many things he speaks in limericks
that guy he does he's smooth it's poetic
hey man you know what they say you can't
open a can if a dog's butt ain't gonna
be shining from tuesday to wednesday
yeah and it's stuff like that that makes
me go yeah i know what he's talking
about yeah exactly rudy jules what's up
with your her what's up with your hair
girl you know what proud about her with
her hair
yeah she was just basically like
yesterday like i'm gonna go get my hat
done and i'm like oh do you need and she
got i got it so she she's self-efficient
wow she she makes appointments on her
own she's independent
she tells her i want to do the billy
eilish with the streaks you know oh you
want to be billy yeah yeah she does her
nails i want to do this
i'm not doing anything with my nails
that's what she's been doing since i've
been back it's her raising of her voice
and i frustrate her right by the way did
you write that welcome back tito bobby
you wrote that give me that let me see
that yeah yeah that's insane
i mean analyze it this is do you want to
talk about minimal effort
oh my god not nothing
what
dude i sign autographs better than 100
yeah you're going to college yeah
terrible handwriting yeah yeah welcome
back oh my god you spelled welcome wrong
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]